when those dears Joey D is here welcome
to mad flavors world I don't know if you
guys know this I used to weigh 405
pounds I lost like 20 on my own but then
I read an article about food and stuff
so what the Weight Watchers and I ended
up losing one from 373 to like 280 on
Weight Watchers and then at 280 my head
got to [ __ ] big I look like I had
[ __ ] I was going through chemo or
something so I said [ __ ] let me just
maintain let me just build a little bit
so I started lifting weights and going
to yoga and all that stuff but I lost my
book I stopped because you have to write
in all your activity with Weight
Watchers and about a month ago
I ran out of space and I used to just go
weigh in and just go get the book but I
haven't been there in a month and it
shows I put on like 12 or 13 pounds but
I wasn't doing the new system I was
doing the old system so I'm going to
them stuff from scratch I don't care
what the [ __ ] I weigh I'm gonna go down
there and I'm gonna try to get down and
try to lose this last 60 pounds but the
difference is I'm gonna do what you
[ __ ] I'm gonna go in today and little
by little in Weight Watchers is not that
bad because it's like the County Jail
diet you don't have to pay for food or
get this so eat apples or you know
oatmeal diet or soup diet none of this
teaches you how to eat from scratch dog
you take it back to basics now I lost
like 90 pounds on Weight Watchers
smoking reefer and doing all that stuff
so it could be done the motto is if you
ain't hungry enough for an apple you
ain't [ __ ] hungry plain and simple so
edit the weight watch I'm taking you
guys with me as far as the mad flavor
world this part of the treats you get
let's do this [ __ ] together if you're a
fat [ __ ] and you want to lose some
weight let's do this together [ __ ]
so I'm gonna wait watches leaves and
wind and get orientation another loop
point system because that the open
system now there's a loop point system
this is what this chart looks like
this drawback I waited at 300 pounds the
goal is 250 you [ __ ] bust all you
[ __ ] are taking a ride with me
I'll be back
that's a Weight Watchers teaches you
happy you have a chicken breast or two
pieces of fried chicken
we'll get this [ __ ] beauty here yeah
this [ __ ] cock-blocking me mad
flavor here Joey Diaz mad flavors world
driving home on the bring a boulevard
gotta go to the bank get some cash out
just came from Weight Watchers got my
orientation to the new points now I'm
[ __ ] go for it guys gotta do this you
know gotta be healthy like I said you go
I go this week I'll show you what I do
next week you [ __ ] go down and see if
you like it we lose weight together it's
a [ __ ] piece of cake right now I'm
driving I'm a little weed store pick up
my [ __ ] tulip for the Lord's Day cuz
today is the Lord's Day [ __ ] and
that's it what's happening beautiful
people mad flavor here Joey Diaz welcome
to math flavors world thank you for
coming back I'm sorry my shirt is off is
hot on a [ __ ] North Hollywood's
about 104 degrees some people out there
frying eggs me I just stay on my
business you know I'm saying as you know
I'm back on Weight Watchers and I've
been in tune and stuff like this you
know bumblebee and the whole [ __ ]
deal it's easy to make to leave you get
a little salt a little pepper you get a
little man hands a couple pickles some
toes boom there you have lunch Bay it is
look how beautiful that is right there
and that's it right wrong try making
tuna fish and you got this [ __ ]
savage on you oh sorry
this guy here as you know my man skinny
thing and
little girl [ __ ] great great what's
happening Gracie say hello say hello
very great Greg a shot but she talks in
trying to time saying they love it like
I got cats hidden and stuff like that
right now alright some cats outside
chillin and like you said you take a
little salt little sea salt
oh you take a little pepper [ __ ] the
Mayo and you go but these guys are gonna
torment me till I give him a little
something check him out there's my
little Siamese skinny right in the front
here there's great gray eat something
great oh boy this is Demi I named the
method the Exodus because he turns to
sleep apnea machine off only while I'm
sleeping he just looks at me and says
what [ __ ] what can he do you guys so
she can look at the other one Cleopatra
Jones over here she hasn't touched a
tuna she thinks she's bad to the bone as
you see you try to make a tuna sandwich
you were surrounded by these animals is
what I live with people like we want to
see the real job this is the real joke
Diaz I'm making a tuna Sam do you think
I'm a [ __ ] sunset smoking cigarettes
people like them know I'm a bum I'm just
bringing you in to let you know how math
flavor does it alright don't forget
about me stay black thank you for
viewing